hello and welcome to this video or damn
jan 04 let's see what we get here yeah
I'm sticking with the news or just too
good an opening to not play but I will
try to play some alternatives to the
bull go to really like to get something
new here and down in my repertoire okay
well this is the the hoop known now
usually fair quite well with ya let's
see what he comes up with here white as
many options here night h4s the
classical mainline a 91 is interesting
yeah yeah this is the same concept that
was played in Smash TV show back in
Reykjavik 1972 and basically since then
that is clear that white has white has
no advantage him still it is played from
time to time very difficult for why to
make some some headway in this position
ok so seems he wants to yeah wants to
take a p6 hmm what you see up to yeah
probably put those rocks on this maybe
yeah I wonder if Nyjah for ism when this
position
hmm huh not quite clear Ruby a drug B 2
and Bishop e3 or Bishop e3 would be I
don't think it's a problem but i wonder
if something more active us better we'll
see what happens okay but should be
three years they move that is irritating
me but I can actually also play queen to
d6 and just protect everything in this
way that's not bad I goes to d2 okay huh
I wonder what is plan is does he really
want to triple their no brings a special
around didn't have that on my radar at
all
okay mm-hmm I think this is an
interesting move winning a tempo here
maybe winning a tempo mmm trading home
trading this is an interesting move I
don't know it could be hmm
hmm i'm unsure trading is interesting
here Bishop d7 is also ok ok I think I'm
trading but I wasn't sure at all about
this
now my night is protecting be six so i
can actually free up my be a drug to go
to f8 an end game with them just bishop
against night could be possibly quite
good for me okay it stressed right now
one book that's good happy with this no
its trading everything yeah that's great
come on and straight yeah maybe you can
draw i think it probably can draw after
the Queen trade but i can probably draw
maybe I shouldn't have played Queen f8
so easily okay that's interesting now
moves like age five he's got twin to be
five that's an interesting interesting
point yeah that's in fact that's really
interesting maybe he can get get this
invasion going
26 is interesting taking I cannot play I
can go here though create Queen g6 boom
don't know yeah Queenie aight i guess
the is the interesting move I but I mean
I don't threaten anything yeah I don't
threaten to take yeah I'm wondering
about h 5 vs is a movie or not the night
is also interesting here i have till
after being cautious with the time
management check my time is really
important here that i don't but i don't
get to slow him
tragedy Queen to f1
yeah so I don't know maybe it just goes
h3 here
time worry I'm not getting too ambitious
here which is very often happens to me
but I think I'm okay and now I'm better
on the clock oh why is that working
check
26 maybe no I'll come on Queenie five
that's it yeah okay yeah yeah yeah okay
I get your point come on Queenie 5nt
resigns just kidding Justin just a piece
of my lip okay cool game yeah i think it
was um very Jewish yeah for very long
time and yeah then he blundered it away
and then I'm all slipped yeah this is
this kind of structure is as I said
typical kind of position here from the
huebner it's um it's probably relatively
equal the structure there are still
ideas though especially in end games
where black sometimes can aim at the
pawns him um I think that was reasonably
well played by by both sides at least
that was my impression I applied 85 to
prevent any a4a files from wide and fix
that porn on 84 this is still the same
as Fisher plated in the game it's just
very difficult to em to make any any
sort of progress in this position I
think here this is just very equal he
avoided the Queen trade I think this was
ok he invaded on c6 and here we have a
position where both sides cannot do much
I was basically ok with the draw at this
point but yeah well somewhere around
here he started started to drift and
this is just blundering a piece and
losses just just a big blunders yeah now
okay I'm all slipped with 25 25 is just
over i win this this pawn as well so
there is not even even some some counter
play
something like this is is promoting the
pawn so the mouse or whatever my sloppy
moving yeah gifted him this game that I
should have one here with Queenie five
um no not much to say it should have
been should have been a draw I guess if
he is not blundering the piece this is
just this is Stella ? he can but should
he do though going back well gee for him
it's not easy the engines still think
that this is a draw just kind of
surprising that looks dangerous but
maybe I'm not getting anywhere I mean
that Queen also has ideas if I go in
there wondering g7 mmm yeah okay if the
engine gives 000 it probably is just
true that position is so concrete that
the computer doesn't make any any
mistakes him it gives this myth Wow I
agree have Mouse problems here it gives
this move as an interesting defense here
I cannot take check this and then queen
36 m SS equal hmm remarkable but
probably there are there are Perpetual's
around the corner and I mean he's also
threatening stuff so this is only a
check happening here with a perpetual
yeah okay there was a bit unlucky with
the mouse slip at the end okay thanks
for watching